Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald
Trump claims he lost the four cell phones
that have just been subpoenaed by Letitia
James. I know what you're going to say,
David. How is that how is that possible? How is it
possible? He would even try to say that, but there
have been no consequences for anything. So why
wouldn't he try to say that? Look at this report
from Business Insider. Donald Trump swears he has
lost four of the cell phones subpoenaed by New
York Attorney General Letitia James. What former
President Donald Trump swears he can't find for
personal and business cell phones that New York's
attorney general has demanded for her probe of
the Trump organization, according to a new court
filing. I am not aware of its current location and
I do not know its current whereabouts,
Trump says repeatedly of his most recent
recent business phone two old flip phones, plus a
Samsung that he had used until it was taken away
from me at some point while I was president. Trump
also swears in the filing. He has no additional
personal business documents to turn over, and
he doesn't own nor use a business computer.
I also do not use a computer for work related
purposes. That does appear to be true that that's
been a thing for a while. There's actually a lot
of CEOs that don't use computers personally just
to avoid exactly this issue where their computer
might be requested for something. The affidavit
was included as part of a larger filing. The
former president has been fined 10,000 a day
since April 26th, when a manhattan judge, Arthur
Angarano, issued a written order holding Trump
in contempt of court for failing to comply with
the attorney general. Letitia James Subpoenas for
Documents and records. Trump currently owes
more than $100,000 in fines. He has started
appealing the contempt order, calling the fine,
exorbitant and unjustified. Trump was known during
his presidency for keeping a cell phone always at
the ready for the firing off of incendiary tweets.
But in his affidavit, Trump says he lost track
of some of these old devices, including the very
phones the attorney general believes could contain
information pertinent to the inquiry. Trump says
he believes the Trump Organization last issued
him a business phone in 2015. It's just gone.
It disappeared. I am no longer. This must be some
kind of typo. I am no longer have the cell phone
in my possession and I am not aware of its current
location. As for two flip phones and the Samsung
he has owned since 2010, those are also
lost. I do not know their current location.
I took the Samsung with me to the White House
and it was taken from me at some point while
I was president. I do not have the Samsung in my
possession. I do not know its current whereabouts.
Currently, I own two personal mobile phones.
One is an iPhone he's had for several years
and he did submit that one for a for a search.
So, I mean, listen. Does anyone believe that
he lost the four phones in question? No,
no. But why not lie about it? Given that
there have been no consequences whatsoever and
that you're just trying to run out the clock,
it seems as though you would deliberately
get rid of the phones, that that would be
certainly one thing to do, and it may technically
be true. I mean, if you go by the letter, he says
he is not aware of its current location.
That's like if I say I threw out a phone,
it would be true that I am not aware of its
current location. Is it in a landfill? Was it
repurposed? Was it you know, who the hell knows?
It's technically true, but it's not the spirit
of the situation. So as we've said before,
with almost all of these different things,
the strategy is obstruct and delay. The January
6th committee. The New York attorney general
investigation, Southern District. All all these
different things that are going on at Georgia
obstruct to the extent that you can and make legal
arguments as to why the obstruction should be
allowed and then delay with January six. We know
the point of delaying it is looking and I have
to choose my words carefully, lest anyone in the
audience get mad at me. It is looking probable,
but it is not guaranteed that Republicans are
going to take the House in November and be sworn
in to that control in January. If that happens,
the January six committee is dead in the water.
And of course, anybody who has been able to
avoid dealing with the January six committee.
You're good. You're free, essentially. And so
that is the purpose there. And with a lot of
these other investigations, you know, in one of
them, it started to become clear that there was no
real interest in charging Trump and investigators
quit. We covered that story a few weeks ago,
so I don't believe any of it. I don't
believe he lost the phones. I mean, if
if he doesn't know where they are, it's because
they've been destroyed, thrown out, whatever.
And it's technically accurate. But we know exactly
what they're doing. And he will almost certainly
get away with it. And we can point fingers and
say, well, it's just Merrick Garland fall there.
It's actually far more complicated
than that. There seems to be no
genuine willingness to seriously consider
charging the president and immediate associates,
and that has opened the door for them to
do whatever they can at the time to justify
not cooperating. That's exactly what Trump is
doing now with this four lost cell phone thing